señor presidente una pregunta muy simple
cree usted que occidente está haciendo
lo suficiente Para apoyar a su país a
usted y para tomar una posición fuerte
frente a Vladimir Putin y posición
hoy Ucrania es un reflejo de lo que las
personas libres del mundo están pensando
la manera como estamos luchando todos
los que están protestando en las calles
creen que lucharían de la misma manera
cuando ellos ven lo que estamos haciendo
Y lo que está haciendo nuestro gobierno
la gente de otros países quiere que sus
gobiernos haga lo mismo
Y tomó
para responder a su pregunta creo que
usted mismo sabe que la gente que se
está tomando las calles en el mundo lo
hace por una razón creen que el mundo
debería hacer más creen que el mundo no
está haciendo lo suficiente
si ese fuera el caso todas estas
personas estarían en las calles
aplaudiendo a sus gobiernos
no podemos abandonar a Ucrania lo que
está pasando aquí es lo que pasará en
Europa mañana todos tienen que pelear
por sí mismos así como por nosotros